hello I'm Aubrey Plaza and as you know
I'm a very busy advertising executive
but on my lunch breaks I like to do
internet quizzes so today I'm gonna do
one on BuzzFeed love their quizzes
they're so random this one is called
answer these yes-or-no questions and
will tell you how you die in a horror
film
I hope my boss doesn't walk in question
number one do you tend to trip over
absolutely nothing when you're running
away from someone / something the
answers are yes no or I trip every once
in a while I'm gonna go with yes I'm
very uncoordinated you're home alone and
it's dark outside you hear a loud and
sudden thump upstairs do you go upstairs
to investigate it my options are yes/no
or techno calling the police normally I
would say heck no I'm calling the police
but I've gotten shamed for that in the
past I can't be a scared woman or a
fussy woman as my ex-husband he used to
say to me to preserve my own integrity
I'm gonna go with no I'll just take
another xanax and go back to bed do you
believe ghosts and/or paranormal
activity exists yes that was easy would
you call yourself more of a lover than a
fighter options are yes/no for both I'm
gonna go with I'm a little bit of both
because I love love and I love to get
nasty I hate myself
do you believe aliens exist yes no or
I'm not sure yes yes I believe aliens
exist yes I believe that we are not the
only people in this galaxy
I'm not some idiot that thinks that
we're special for some reason we out of
your freaking mind if you think there
are no aliens do you believe that the
zombie apocalypse is nigh yes no or I
have no clue I'm going to say I have no
clue because in my mind that just means
I don't care do you overall consider
yourself an optimistic person hmm yes no
or I'm a healthy balance now I think
normally other people would probably say
that I'm not an optimistic person but
I'm gonna say yes which means that I am
an optimistic person I am optimistic
that I am up
mystic and that is the most optimistic
thing I could do you're given a doll as
a gift
it's creepy you place it on a shelf in
your living room when you wake up the
next morning the doll has moved to the
couch
is it haunted options are yes no or no
that gave me a doll I'm gonna go with
who the heck gave me a doll and why the
heck are they moving things around in my
house it's probably the neighbors would
you ever use a Ouija board to try and
connect with spirits yes no or maybe I'm
gonna go with yes because I've done that
several times and I have connected with
spirits so that was easy do you tend to
lose your keys a lot at pivotal moments
when you need them the most
yes No wow this is oddly specific I tend
to lose my keys pretty much at every
moment I'm definitely a bag lady I have
a lot of things in my bag I usually do
the method of closing my eyes and
rummaging around with my hands and I go
by touch to find my keys but I'm
assuming that that isn't helpful when
you're being chased down by a
psychopathic murderer do you believe you
are mentally and physically prepared to
survive a horror movie situation yes no
or it depends on the situation yes I
mean you can't mentally or physically
prepare for anything so yes and finally
do you like scary movies I'm gonna say
sure why not
is this a real quiz am I gonna actually
get an answer at the end so I should
have actually been clicking on things
right it's this new operating system
they give you at your job
it's like felling you know you got
strangled by a possessed doll this is a
trick isn't it I was always gonna get
that answer because this is a setup my
answer is you got strangled by a
possessed doll you're gifted a popular
doll for your birthday by a close friend
only one problem the doll is a murderous
psychopath with the taste for blood who
strangles you in your sleep
so much for your new best friend and
there is an image of Chucky pointing to
pistols at me and I just think this is
very fitting for obvious reasons because
we all know why I'm here
I'm on my lunch break and I'm gonna get
fired very soon and then I'll have to
pick a new career path starring in
horror films like child's play coming
out on June 21st in the
near you
[Music]